[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
bet five dollars to win 150 in bonus
bets at draftkings.com new customers
don't wait throw down at least five
bucks on any pre-game money line for the
chance to win 150 in bonus Spence at
draftkings.com he's the ESPN NBA analyst
J.J Reddick joining us on the program
good to see you again what impact did
last night's game with Denver and
Philadelphia have on your vote for MVP
it actually didn't have any impact and
that's unfortunate because I really felt
like had Joel embeden played it would it
would have given a little more clarity
to the situation look Joelle has I think
two more chances to really put his stamp
on the MVP Philly has a game against
Boston in another game against Giannis
in Milwaukee so he still has two
opportunities to I think sway some
people here but as of right now I look
it's it's a dead Lock between those
three guys for me yeah I'm sure just
disappointed as a basketball fan because
this is what you want
and I know that it's you know there's
probably load management here but you
know this is what the NBA has given us
JJ like we we know that these things
happen I don't know how serious this
injury is I don't know how much it
mattered that he was going to have this
game in Denver after he smoked you know
the Joker in Philadelphia but as a fan
you know it's hard to have appointment
viewing anymore during the regular
season
that's fair I will say this I I know
Joelle very well I played with him for
two seasons we're we're uh very close
friends and I know how much this matters
to him this particular word it does and
if he could have played last night he
would have played I I believe that I do
feel for the fans I I feel for anybody
who uh is a a fervent supporter and
viewer of the NBA that we don't always
get to see the matchups that we want to
see on a nightly basis because of
some somewhat because of load management
but also look injuries are up the game
is played in a different way I mean we
look Dan we have this second Spectrum
tracking data cameras in every Arena
right we've had that for 10 years we've
got 10 years of data and over the course
of time in those 10 years essentially
the court has gotten 20 percent bigger
that's 20 percent more area
that a player has to cover the pace is
up significantly so you're doing more on
a basketball court you're covering more
space you're doing it faster transition
is up uh you know the the three pointers
are up which means you have to guard
further out and and so I think it it
some of it is load management some of it
is legitimate injuries yeah
well and look embed is just getting the
brunt of that because it's right now
he's a wonderful player and you can give
him the MVP I just there's value in
showing up and he's missed what 14 games
this year I don't know how much that
impacts the voters here but it was just
more of a fan I was disappointed that I
didn't get to see it because I want to
be I want him to earn it I want him to
win it I don't want him to back in where
we go you know he missed like 17 games
and uh Jokers teams best record like all
of those things because I voted before
and got criticized because I voted
Jordan every year and then people say
what about the year Barkley had or Carl
Malone I go yeah but Mike's going to win
the championship so I I valued guys who
are going to play and I knew they were
going to win whether that was fair or
not in my mind how do I equate what is
value to you what is value to me
well I think it's very subjective yeah
and I do think the criteria does change
year to year
um people talk about narrative in sports
all the time narratives are actually
based in fact narrative is simply
storytelling that's all it is and so I
think The Narrative of what the MVP
means in a particular season is
different in Prior seasons and I don't
think we can look at historical
precedences when voting on this year's
MVP or next year's MVP we have to ask
ourselves
who is the most valuable player this
season and it's very clear it's three
guys you bring up the point about games
missed look Giannis sat out last night
that was his 16th game Miss there's been
one player in NBA history who has missed
15 or more games in one MVP that was
Bill Walton who missed 24 games in 1978.
here's the other thing about Giannis
his personal win percentage went on the
court this year is 74.6 there's been
seven times in NBA history where Guys
average 30 a game
and had a personal win percentage of 75
or better
six of those times the guy won the MVP
so how do we talk about these games
missed in the modern era in this in
today's NBA it's unrealistic to expect
any player I'm sorry any player any
player much less an MVP to play 80 81 82
games it's not gonna happen this is the
new Norm unless the schedule changes
unless we reduce the games
this is what's gonna happen and so we
kind of have to look at it through that
lens I think and look jokic uh
he to me he's been the front runner
there was a two-week stretch there where
Denver was awful yeah and Joelle made
this incredible push in March 10
straight games of 30 or more shooting uh
50 or more 50 or better from the field
like it's a three-man race they're all
deserving and to me I I found out over
the weekend I'm gonna have a vote it's
gonna come down to the last few days of
the regular season I'm looking at
giannis's personal win percentage I'm
looking at how many games he misses how
many games Joelle misses I'm looking at
Denver's record that stuff matters
we're talking to JJ Redick ESPN NBA
analyst I I think there's voter fatigue
I think that happens I think that that I
think it happened with Jordan I think
they were looking for a new story
whether it's fair or not Barkley win it
Malone winning and they were great those
years I think there's voter fatigue with
jokic I I really believe they're going
do we want to put him in there with bird
Wilt and Bill Russell
and do we factor in what he doesn't do
in the playoffs JJ well look I'll push
back on that a little bit Derek it's not
what jokic doesn't do
it's clearly not what jokic doesn't do I
mean this is a guy who over the course
is is playoff careers averaged 25 10-6
last year against Golden State a top two
defense he averaged 31-13 and six on 57
shooting from the field it's not what he
does in the playoffs let's just
acknowledge jokic has yet to have an
All-Star teammate and certainly he has
talented teammates Jamal Murray Michael
Porter Jr Aaron Gordon's having a
fantastic season
but some of this is on his teammates
like that that's that's the nature of
our sport yeah and and so he's
simultaneously making his teammates
better there's a number of ways we can
measure that there's a number of ways we
can measure that
he's making them better
but what's their ceiling
does he have a real Robin right
I would make an argument by the way that
you also need a bunch of alfreds too you
need the butlers you need the Butlers to
do the Dirty Work
your point Dan look revision is history
we are more informed as voters in 2023
than we've ever been we have every
single metric in front of us
um
I think you go back and you re-vote on a
number of years in the in in and you
would change your vote like that's just
we we have more information it's to me
it actually is less about storytelling
and it's a it's it's going back to that
basic question who is the most valuable
player Jordan should probably have more
MVPs Lebron should have more MVPs Shaq
should have more MVPs yeah
but I go back to Russell Westbrook we
got enamored with the triple double
what was he on his sixth place team like
that doesn't happen but because we had
something convenient of a triple double
that hasn't has happened since Oscar oh
my God and I thought as much as I love
watching Russ how valuable was he
well so I think there's two things to
look at there Dan number one keep in
mind uh this was right after Kevin
Durant left Oklahoma City and so the
warriors were the best team in
basketball
for three straight Seasons up until when
clay and Kevin got hurt
I don't know that you can give an MVP to
that team so to someone on that team
given how stacked they were look I was
in the NBA I was competing against them
both with the Clippers and the
Philadelphia 76ers trying to win a
championship that was an uphill climb
for anyone
with Russ
win shares per 48. it's a very simple
metric right it's the it's the stat
that's most closely associated
with MVP and Russ measured out very well
that I think he was top five that year
top three
I know he didn't lead the league he led
the league in value over replacement
player like there's an advanced stat
like sometimes these things line up but
if Durant doesn't go JJ if he's already
with golden state
like do we look at Golden State only
because Durant left Oklahoma City to go
there as opposed to if he had already
been on Golden State and been a teammate
there would we have viewed that
differently because it feels like oh my
God he joined them and they're already
great
personally no personally no I I think
you go back and you look at the context
of the roster that Oklahoma City had
they had 48 wins that 48 and 34.
you look at what Russ did
from the field you know his shot
creation that year LED an assist percent
like he did a number of things besides
just the rebounding and the triple dub
like it's such an arbitrary like oh yeah
measuring stick right yeah it's kind of
like with jokic this year like who
who cares who cares who cares if he
averages you're not on your podcast we
shouldn't I know we shouldn't give him a
triple double we shouldn't give the MVP
if he averages a triple-double and we
should not give him the MVP if he
doesn't average a triple exactly Russ
was awesome that year he was a deserving
MVP uh I know that it's uh contractually
required by the FDA that I ask you
something about the Lakers right
I hey I worked at the mothership for 18
years I know how this I know how this
goes
um how threatening are they when healthy
I think they're a real threat in the
west to win the Western I was just
having this conversation before I jumped
on your show with someone that works
here at ESPN
you could legitimately talk me into
seven teams that's how that's how crazy
the West is and and I think there's
teams that are better than other teams
but as you know Dan the playoffs a lot
of times do come down to match-ups and I
I
I think there's six teams I can make a
strong argument for that could
potentially win the West depending on
how these matchups play out and I'd put
the Lakers as the seventh team that
could potentially win the West when
fully healthy Anthony Davis fully
engaged on both ends of the floor LeBron
being LeBron their roster got
significantly better post All-Star break
they have shooting they have more depth
Jared Vanderbilt has made a big
difference on the defensive end
they're a more complete team where for
all of last season and for the better
part of this season going up until the
trade deadline they were not a it was
not a competent roster it was not a
roster where the pieces fit and now you
see
how those pieces could fit and obviously
we haven't seen a ton of LeBron with
that roster post deadline but I could
make an argument that they have they
have a chance to win the west and and to
me
being able to talk about the Lakers in a
good way is it's a positive thing I've
spent the last two seasons since I
retired just absolutely murdering okay
what happens when you go into the
rundown meeting and you know that it's
going to be brought up like we gotta get
LeBron in the show or get the Lakers in
the show right
I've accepted it
it used to be when I was there it was
about the Red Sox and the Yankees where
we had to get Duke North Carolina into
the conversation
so I uh who else Terrell Owens was all
you know there were certain guys certain
teams that uh Brett Favre you had to get
him into the rundown every show it's
like how do we do look look I I I uh I'm
jumping on first take here in in a few
minutes yeah
um to to talk some NBA but I will tell
you you know as someone who watches the
show when I'm not on and is someone who
comes in twice a week to do the show
um I think there personally I think
there's some sort of conspiracy going on
with Lamar Jackson and Aaron Rodgers
because that's all we talk about okay
that's I know you talk about I know it's
got to get the clicks man we gotta get
the clicks I know if I have this idea
what if we did a retired guys shooting
contest at the All-Star game where you
let's say you and Ray Allen some of
these other guys Reggie Miller they got
picked so a current player and a retired
player team up for a three-point
shooting contest
Dan that is one of the greatest ideas
I've heard we need to pitch this are you
in we need to we need to yeah I'll do it
I don't really shoot any I can't I can't
really play anymore uh I'll sh I'm
coaching my oldest son so when I'm in
the gym with him and his team I'll shoot
around a little bit I would need a few
weeks to get my reps right Ray is the
guy I swear I swear I think Ray like
shoots 500 shots a day he could play
yeah he could still play now and Reggie
you know you guys don't have to move
around and or you could alternate racks
it would be throw Larry Bird in there I
mean come on even at 65 I'm still I'm
sure he still has a burner so you you
that would be a burner is that what you
said yeah like a heater
yeah he's got a flamethrower you know do
you have a Larry Bird Story
uh I personally know I've I've met him
one time it was uh I think it was my
senior year
um at Indianapolis final four uh Adam
Morrison and I co-chaired one of the
national Player of the Year Awards in
him and Oscar were at the ceremony which
was a very cool moment for me what about
Jordan do you have a Jordan story
I mean I I played against Michael I can
pick up when I was in college we did the
uh Santa Barbara UC Santa Barbara Jordan
Camp
um played pick up against him you know
it was it was a blur I mean Jordan for
anybody that grew up in the 90s is is
the goat you know it's he's the guy he's
an icon he's the guy that made us fall
in love with love with basketball and
made us fall in love with the NBA
um so yeah I mean I Jordan's never like
talked trash to me about the Duke UNC
thing or it's mostly I'm telling you
it's other UNC guys yeah it's other UNC
guys I get a text every I get a text
every year
every year like clockwork from Harrison
Barnes how much are we putting on the
game tonight
I'll let you always pay our debts we
always pay our debts I'll let you get
ready for First Take and uh you get to
talk about Aaron Rodgers and uh Lamar
Jackson I'll be talking about Joel
embien I'm sure oh you're right thank
you okay yeah thank you good to talk to
you again that's a JJ Redick one of our
favorites hit uh ESPN NBA analyst
joining us on behalf of DraftKings bet
five dollars to win 150 in bonus bets at
draftkings.com new customers don't wait
throw down at least five on any pregame
money line for a chance to win 150 in
bonus bets draftkings.com